you
here we go it's the Kappa Arena there we
go
we have the Kings as Kappa if you would
like that option it's available now
that's the first and last time I'll be
doing it because I need to conserve
every second every second for these
tournaments here let's go b6 I don't
care about my pond here it's actually a
bit distracting to see this little
figure here perfectly honest he does
move as you will see right here I pre
moved King takes bishop there he is he's
unleashed okay let's go here I'm not
quite sure why they're giving up their
light square bishop okay
hitting here my knight is pretty much
already secured pressure on that pond
I'm hitting now second time can think
about g5 just to open up the H file okay
let's take here take on g3 of pond takes
I'm hitting the knight as well okay now
this is collapsing they can't take I
have this covered enough the H and G
files are going to be ripped open let's
do it right now let's take let's take
care no matter what and get my rooks
active if a big time advantage here
throw this check in no matter what 7
seconds it's here and push cannot be
stopped
promoting next let's take care first I
don't have any time
okay back to tournament it's the kappa
arena less 28 minutes and change a lot
of players already have their first game
in and all right there won't be any more
time spent typing out Kappa all right
either player could type cap outside of
the chat and your King turns into Kappa
Ferrari okay let's go with building a
center let's see how black reacts to
that
and let's push this deep on down they're
gonna take and open up the e-file I'm
gonna see about that they might push my
knight to the f5 square they're gonna
look to win upon okay this has to be
super annoying no pressure against g7
how are they defending if I do this move
now it's gonna sack on g7 but not so
fast let's pin this night this has to be
uncomfortable on g6 huh let's back up I
want to use this Bishop as an attacker
let's go here
and threatening some dangerous stuff
let's secure my knight position first
it's very annoying that move let's
challenge that rook he's very active
spent a lot of time so far and hmm let's
play here and now finally hit that
pinned piece it's been pinned for awhile
no I take here and then here I have to
watch out for g2 no actually I could
have could have done some stuff with
that
I'm going astray I don't have any time
either f6 is hit ah too fast too fast oh
I'm getting made it on g2 or h1 pick
your favorite the Ferrari is too fast
and strong uh okay well it's gonna be oh
that it doesn't get any easier either
okay let's roll so far tough pairings
Ferrari and this guy okay so far I like
my position I like my position in the
other one I know I had juicy stuff I was
missing all the juiciness I think
okay I have a tool on majority in the
center wonderful what are you gonna do
with it though tell me that what are you
gonna do with that Center improve your
night position would you get b5 in
squeeze the clean side grab some space
gain a temple against the Queen improve
your night position I don't want to
trade I have more space let's get here a
seven second lead I had to lead the last
time I played him still didn't work out
well Knights gonna move get all my
pieces working okay they broke the pin
and I should really be looking for some
sacrifices against their Kings side
they've we can see for now my Knights
are in beautiful squares let's go my
Queens gonna sneak over here there
Knight can't move so easily now still
can't move what can we do to force that
night to move okay let's take here pre
move that let's get rid of this guy mmm
Queen here I have a big time edge let's
push in the center keep pushing
gonna have some trades rook here I'm on
g4 improve my rook
this is collapsing this should be good
okay they drop their queen they gave it
up on purpose they resigned back to
tournament that was very important I'm
in 11th whoo okay d4 we start with let's
maybe launch an H pawn against this
structure it's not correct but you could
get away with a lot of stuff in bullet
I'm gonna try and make it work okay open
up the H file alright Bishop g4 into
here where's the king going running for
his life
Oh take a free Queen she's super free
she was super free man push
follow-through why am I not falling
through my Jeep on push
okay let's take here get my rip to the
seventh I have this secure
there's no Bishop move with any there's
no exciting Bishop move there the Queen
here dangerous dangerous stuff
let's check I'm getting this full piece
now and my Jeep on continues to march
the night spent I had discoveries and
stuff let's do this take care making one
threat that's mate back to tournament
thirteen ten eight eight eight and where
am I at six I'm not on the front page
got to get to the front page for it to
be exciting okay make front page and
then we'll talk about points I've said
that before
alright let's grab some space so let's
bring force d4 which is coming under
some heavy heavy fire Queen takes b-29 a
four winds and we're gonna have Bishop
c5 94 let's do this clean check I have
c3 I think this is working
okay yawn b5 overnight c5 gotta take
like this b5 still Knight c5 is this
still on I believe it should be I pitch
it back and then b5 let's get castle
before it's maybe too late let's back up
I don't release the pressure on my
knight okay now it's defender my bishop
I can think about c5 let's get my rook
here c5 soon c4 let's open this up and
prove my knight position Bishop c6 I
give them a kick okay this is getting
broken down let's not be too quick to do
that pre move here soon
okay let's recapture my bishop queen
trade take with my pawn okay this is
winning full rook I take here this it
mate soon
this running away stuff here and then
here mate next back determine seventeen
thirteen twelve ten ten Ferrari slipped
up
John Madden is now on board let's stop
there quick queenside castling queenside
FINCAD oh ok they like that Queen C to
move let's sneak that move in there and
we're gonna get a little crazy here on
a3 I'm gonna play here first it's gonna
get wild I'm gonna drop a pawn mmm let's
take here and let's get castle soon yeah
so I know about that idea but I'll try
and make it work somehow sacrifice is
over here okay let's open up in the
center there King is still in the middle
okay let's get f5 in pawn push pawn
takes pawn push okay this is big it's a
fork and I'm threatening a discovered
attack let's take this guy and hang on
to that pond rookie - let's throw this
check in discovery checks okay let's
give another check here another check
soon okay they've had enough of my
knight clearly clean here queen f for a
time edge okay here let's grab this pawn
and this one no I didn't realize that
that was possible I need to get this
pawn need to hang on to him they're
gonna connect their pawns yeah I
shouldn't have allowed that okay let's
take here get rid of their knight and
defend my oh my goodness fortunately I
have that move a counter pin got a take
here and then crawl up into a ball oh
boy hopefully they don't
do anything too quick throw some checks
in um don't go too fast please start
running with this pond oh boy I can't
breathe
I can never breathe if it gets too close
you just know I'm not breathing properly
I lose the ability to breathe properly
25:14 we're not even at the halfway
point
okay oh man - crazy - crazy these
tournaments I tell you
alright let's follow through with being
Kettering ah man okay it's really night
in the center focus on the dark squares
and give free pawns away I guess I could
take here and damage their structure
though
let's support this okay not quite sure
what I'm doing I want to keep my night
around b5 the e5 play on the Queen side
why am i playing so positionally I
should be looking for more dangerous
moves stronger moves they're probably
there I'm just missing them okay this is
a fork I have more pieces on it they
missed that at night he's a pest they
could take my night I have a discovered
trick let's go here this games need to
end much faster no Queen trade setting
up sneaky stuff on each - let's give
this check ooh
this is good it's another check
here push leave it still open I'm
threatening me oh I was threatening h2
stuff could still try stuff with my
knife
and clean let's get my king and my
knight working
where's the main push of G - that's a
matin - back to tournament that one felt
like it took forever 29 18 16 16 knock
this guy out
I can't someone else needs to knock him
out again
he's got three more games in than me at
least okay
caro-kann is this really the way to do
it to get some quick wins you play the
caro-kann you play that variation
against the caro-kann there's no H pawn
attack what do you there's nothing to
even bite at they haven't moved their
Jeep on I got a run in reverse to break
a pin I get the bishop hair but it's
just a game that doesn't end fast enough
okay
I must just drop my Brooke I was very
played b3 terrible terrible okay they're
gonna have to play Bishop h2
let's keep here there's a restriction
now placed on their queen maybe here
more aggressive could I move forward a
bit more please more forward please push
up here finally get that fork Knight
here that was a move although I take in
pac-man mode watch out Bishop h6 it's a
killer here first
devastating moves happening maybe on the
back rank vac renewed Queen e8 take the
knight let's do that clean here
tough to untangle they have to take good
care of their back rank let's play here
I have e1 still covered they might miss
that hope chess ok g7 watch out for g7
okay g7 you can't stop mate now it's
happening soon right here Oh kitchen
sink back determent they resigned 33 22
11 back it's definitely doable if we get
paired up I'm - must-win clearly
I had a good position I should have
wrecked his pawn structure earlier on f6
John Madden let's not give up a pawn
this time let's not do that
I get d4 in and hang on to a pond okay
now I'm winning material with this valve
I can have a queen trade how are they
castling let's go here I want to grab a
tempo against the Queen so much for that
whoo I like the looks of that one scary
let's go here Wow would you quit
bothering my queen please get out of
there man you're no good you're no good
to me on that g5 square this night needs
to go somewhere else he's being a super
pest okay something an accidents gonna
happen on c4 soon let's play here first
I'm gonna push soon to castle rip te 8
the king better run fast ok with that
get the a file ok let's open up this
let's break up this pawn who's pinned no
they could take my bishop no I'll watch
out Knight let's go here bishop pair
let's grab this pawn and keep pushing
hang out of my Bishop 27 seconds ok
watch out for mates still have mating
ideas here if one of the rooks leaves
the back rank there's big trouble and
there it is that's made next they
resigned back to tournament 38:26 Kyle
43 he just finished I think we're gonna
get paired up oh it's a big one if we do
it's a must-win otherwise this is
already over and done with and over and
done with tournament no this is tough
he's in third he's on my heels no beef
I've seen what's that move about was
that that's got to be a mouse slip I
just get angry seeing that move no
that's not really what went on
okay I'm pushing in the center let's
roll here please
let's continue it's build keep building
secure my Center gained a tempo against
the Queen Queen trade they're gonna
offer I don't want a Queen trade I'm
looking to attack they have a weakened
King side castle position how do I get
my Knight to f5 that's not the way to do
it mmm let's do this I Knight to f5
please Knight trade ok let's go here
where's that night going let's go here
first otherwise I can't pivot on the on
this III square ok serious issues here
force their hand I want to open up the F
file why did I give that square up hmm
ok they didn't go there let's undermine
this side of the board here let's break
it open Wow clean here rook up and over
let's take that pawn bishop spin to mate
threat here
oh that's very helpful back determine
they dropped their queen
who that one was like way too fast 48:30
he keeps berserk he's just extending his
lead
but somebody please knock him out 10
minutes remain 18 points even if we got
paired up and I beat him that's a big if
still a mountain a mountain ok maybe I
have to sneak in some super fast wins
I'm not comfortable with berserk Inge
I'm not fast enough
this site with my mouth speed so it's
not really gonna work out well ooh
that's helpful they might resign I could
use a quick resigner they resigned back
to tournament hang on 48:34 less than 10
48 34 22 okay he's probably ready to win
and rack up five more points maybe he'll
keep Reiser King and someone will be
fast enough okay let's try efore let's
try some gambit let's go here get some
development in okay they're declining
that and let's play here get my knight
out and we're gonna launch this H pun on
h6 I'm going to allow the capture if you
want to open up the H file I'm gonna do
that let's back up and maybe I'm taking
their Knight let's take like this I get
the G file just don't want to move my
bishop sacking here definitely let's
take that bishop pawn push may threat on
h7 difficult to defend rook takes rook
takes there's no Queen G and I control
this square they resigned back to term
it that was a big win 40 and 50 238 I
think we're getting paired up right now
no we're not getting paired up john
madden again it's like every game i win
he wins like two seconds later yeah what
else you expect I mean really it's the
Ferrari he is fast okay that Knights
gonna get pushed around again
alright I mean to do that let's try this
let's try it again hitting the Queen I
can't block with my Bishop Queen takes
Knight I have a fork available c2 that's
difficult to parry two forks they might
resign it's another check
are they resigning they're not resigning
here I guess some trades in
it's another piece they might resign now
being down to pieces no not quite
let's give a check let's go here
discover checks ok here Knight takes
there's real here mate that's helpful
back determinant that was quick 52 4228
7 minutes and change still trying I'm
still trying maybe I need the help of
Kappa I don't have time for that though
ok I already played this guy twice ok
Bishop c4 on f7 it's a castle I get my
night out f4 f5 let's do this get two
pawns here let's go back here ok I have
a very active rook to take care of my
pawn though ok they've weakened their
dark squares a lot I don't want to trade
ok let's go here
can I get my queen into h6 and that's so
fast
rook f4 go for Queen g5 force that Queen
away from defending the knight Queen h6
I'm in a pin I can't move my rook anyhow
fine I guess we're gonna do this I feel
like I should still have some attack
though it's a knight f6 ah let's go here
ok this is tough
this is tough I'm just looking to win I
should have doubled up rooks
neck-and-neck timewise I'm not sure
where I'm going to my knight just I'm
making fast moves here trying to play
quick guess we'll take like this
as any move go faster have a time edge
hang up get this check go fast really
fast give some checks with the night
anything you need to just burn their
time back to tournament they're down on
time 5646 is still a tenth still a
10-point lead that is a lot ten points
not quite sure why I played Queen c2
let's get this break in its take I want
to grab some space no clean trade yeah
no Queen trade I don't want to give that
pawn up let's go here first
no don't want that let's get him out of
there let's take this pawn let's go back
am I really I'm asking for some trouble
maybe let's go here Bishop d3 now they
still have this this looks very weird
but I'm gonna do it finally I could gain
a temple against the Queen without
dropping g2 let's play here
Knight here stuff Knight f6 I get the
Queen oh my goodness what a terrible
oversight I have still a Jeep on and
their Jeep on is not pinned what are you
doing
oh man in my tricky night is long gone
yes he is long gone I thought it was
being fancy with that little tactic okay
I still have hope still have hope can
they get my pawn they could have got my
pawn
yeah they could have tracked that pond
down easily King position oh boy oh boy
I'm in big trouble
time burning is all I have oh oh boy
this is gonna be painful there's a
bishop check I could have lost my last
piece there oh they didn't take that oh
my goodness
how many lives am I gonna have oh I
don't have any time either they're down
on time oh I thought I lost that time I
should have been checkmated seven times
over seven times seven that checkmated
but I am I gonna terrible terrible
terrible three terrible's that warrants
three terrible's okay uh let's take that
good grief man that was an ugly ugly
game I'm seeing ah I don't know what I'm
seeing I don't have answers I'm lacking
answers oh I had a G pun Oh Knight f6
taking advantage of the pin he's not
pinned back to basics man back to basics
ridiculous really it's ridiculous let's
crash through on e6 please let's grab
this pawn why not why am I not smashing
through here it's another very important
question
I have enough pieces on that my knight
is ready to pounce on the physician uh
just like that double attack against the
queen who is pinned also Queen takes
rook dead
very deadly and now I'm on g7 they
resigned back to tournament where do we
stand where did i do what did I do
69 54 oh yeah what can you do man this
guy you guys three more games in even if
I want I want to beat him there you go
make it seem like it's okay to lose a
game huh you got to win every game
that's 1654 I gotta go for quick kills
and they just they're just non-existent
non-existent D for D for build that
Center D 5 kicked the night around can I
sneak one more win in I'm not gonna get
first but I could fight I could still
fight let's pin the bishop for starters
Queen d5 maybe no matter what no hang on
that was maybe not such a good pre move
as it turns out it should be okay I feel
like I want to just take the knight they
have trouble developing their Queen side
let's go here ready take the knight next
let's do it
what let's go here
don't fall for mate on g2 which they
were right YouTube just now oh man okay
let's play here let's go here Queen
takes f6 and then Queen g7 main xed one
of these two right there back to
tournament and it is over the kappa
arena
74/54 38 36 29 to fast to furious
a lot of fives a lot of razor King
berserk rate 30% who did anyone type out
Kappa anyone have their kings turn into
Kappa and that one I don't think any of
my opponents
had that pop up but okay good games all
that was another fun one
all right
you